I mean this is real Candor but you know
as a man like there's nothing funnier
than when you finish masturbating you
know there's no more humbling moment and
I like to think about the fact that like
the richest famous most powerful person
in the world they jerk off
you know the most powerful man in the
world jerks off I'm sure you know all of
them do I mean you probably know them so
you could ask but in that moment where
you just you you come and you go
am I doing like what the now I gotta
wipe that like oh a good Lord and
there's this feeling of but a second ago
this seemed like a great idea and it was
by the way it was a great idea but but
you there's this moment this Satori you
know where you just go
oh like what this is so silly well like
that's love that's sex like it's crazy
like when you read
other people's infidelity
the text messages the emails because I
have to do that all the time and I'll
tell you how we make the sausage
in a divorce lawyer's office this some
of the most entertaining moments is
dramatic readings allowed of people's
infidelity exchanges but they're lovers
the sexts yeah the sex and the the like
you know like it's just so ridiculous
because people have to go through like
all kinds of gymnastics to be able to
meet and have sex in weird places and
you know
and you're reading this and you're
reading these texts and you kind of go
like oh my God and by the way like I've
represented some very powerful people
and you read their texts with their
lover or even their spouse like even
their spouse you know
and they're just pathetic I mean they're
just like so not powerful they're so
like hey babe you know I I have a I have
a remain totally nameless I have a very
powerful wealthy famous former client
where there's a whole series of texts
about is my dick weird
which by the way I think the answer is
if you have to ask if you have a weird
dick the answer is probably yes because
I've I've owned one and I've never
thought it's weird
but but I I
the fact that you're having this
discussion like it's absurd it's
hilarious like love is hilarious it's
bizarre it's such a weird vulnerability
it's such a a basic visceral human need
you know it it really is something that
we just
you know it's mysterious it it it but it
but it doesn't have to be that
complicated I don't think that even
betrayal like I said it doesn't have to
be that complicated I think we can frame
it differently yeah you can laugh at the
whole thing I mean I
I think what we don't often do with
ourselves
is uh look back at text or look back at
emails or look back at Google search I
did that recently just looking at what I
searched for like 10 years ago 15 it's
like forget last week just look at your
Google searches
last week and you're like wait a minute
what why did you just search for this
right 50 times right like why did The
Karate Kid 3 pop in yeah exactly why and
like you're like where is Ralph Macchio
now where who is he dating yeah uh wise
and then mother and then yeah and then
you're like and then a restaurant nearby
yeah like how did I go from this to that
but but it made sense at the time so so
when you ask someone
how did our relationship Fall Apart
it's like looking at the Google search
history of yourself from 10 years you
don't even know why you were thinking
about those things yeah and now you want
to understand why you did what you did
felt what you felt she felt what she
felt she did what she did and why the
two of you how you impacted each other
and interacted with each really you
think that's doable
but you've so you've in in the courtroom
does that come up like text messages
that resulted in uh with whoever you're
cheating with yeah I mean you know
cheating doesn't come up as much because
most states are no fault States now so
why someone's getting divorced whether
it's infidelity or you know it doesn't
matter there's no good spouse bonus or
bad spouse penalty well there isn't I
mean you know I'm wearing that like
that's well you can have we've had times
where we have to prove infidelity
because we want to prove what's called
wasteful dissipation of marital assets
which means that you were spending money
that was marital money
on a Paramore That's What the legal name
for a ex you know for a boyfriend or
girlfriend in the marriage and usually
the person calls it you know that
or that piece of but we call them
Paramore yeah the Paramore yeah and the
the the you know sometimes we have to
prove inclination and opportunity we
have to prove that this person had the
inclination to cheat and that they had
the opportunity to cheat and then we
want to show that okay so when they went
away that should be considered
dissipation and marital assets so if you
go out to dinner with your brother you
didn't dissipate the marital estate but
if you bought your Paramore a Tiffany
bracelet that would be a dissipation
marital assets and the person's entitled
to a credit back for that from what was
taken out of the marital estate so we do
sometimes have to authenticate text
messages on the witness stand or in
depositions you know and what's
interesting about that is the way people
approach it like people sometimes try to
pretend oh no this is just my good
friend you know and which is just like
you kill your credibility you know if
you oh no she's just my very good friend
she's not she's not that makes no sense
whatsoever for or no we were just
friends at that point and then several
months later is when we once this
marriage was over that's when we got
together as partner right that's
ridiculous
but sometimes people just own it
just own it like I did a deposition of
an executive once and
you know posing counsel I thought they
were going to really hit him they were
like and looking at this credit card
receipt what was this charge for for
this hotel he was like oh that was for a
hotel room that I got with uh with my
girlfriend
and you were married yes yes what did
you where did you stay at the hotel it
was we didn't even stay we actually just
did like an afternoon delight rolled
around in bed for the day
yeah and it was like well now you know
took all the Thunder out of that what's
the downside of doing that that seems
like there wasn't it actually I think
helped his credibility it was my client
so I thought it was the right move we
hadn't really discussed it in advance
but he he was naturally intelligent
enough to go yeah my credibility like
I'm not gonna lie under oath I'll admit
what it was but I'll do it in such an
you know we did it like at the end like
Eminem at the end of eight mile like it
was very like yeah I cheated on her with
this person now tell these people
something they don't know about me you
know and and that's kind of how I try to
as a trial lawyer we we actually in my
firm refer to it as the Eight Mile
strategy which is like we will if I know
there was a text message sent you know
you piece of I hope you die my
client sent that text message to his
co-parent
I I on my examination of my client I
will say I'd like to have this marked
for identification shown to the witness
what is that it's a text message
who's it to
a plaintiff
you sent it yeah read it out loud for
the court
uh do I have to
I think you should
uh you're a piece of uh s does it say s
no what does it say well it's a
profanity so you say it
uh you piece of I hope that you die
yeah you sent that to her yes why
I was really mad do you think that was
good
no do you think it's helpful for your
co-parenting relationship with her
no why did you send it then
you know she sent me like 50 texts
exactly like that and I never responded
and I pushed it down every time and then
finally I just blew up at her if you had
it to do over again would you do it
differently you know I wish I could say
I would but the truth is I'm human and I
was at my limits and I'm watching
opposing counsel cross out entire sheets
of their cross-examination because it's
gone now they thought that they had
their like Perry Mason moment they had
their like did you order the code red
moments and it's gone now because if you
just own and accept your fault or your
issues in the relationship
you can take a lot of the power out of
that
and I wish we wouldn't take text
seriously
I don't think we should have substantive
discussions via text I think text was
designed for are you here yes 15 minutes
away or I got here safely love you like
that substantive discussions are people
love having arguments via text and I
have to say when you read other people's
text messages as I am often forced to do
yeah it is amazing
because just like that Google history
you were talking about
I don't know how the hell you got from
one thing to another like I was just
reading on actually on on the way here
in the car I was reading through a text
exchange between two co-parents in the
middle of a custody thing that I'm I'm
involved in
and
it's
you never cared about anything and I'm
gonna you have no right to take the kids
and then the next day nothing in between
the next day
Maddie got a a you know a good great
honor science thing oh that's great
she's doing so well it makes me so happy
yeah her teacher said she's doing really
well yeah that's really great to see
I'll be there about 15 minutes late no
problem see you then
wait like it was a day ago was there
some I want to know was there a phone
conversation in between where one of you
went hey man listen I'm really sorry
about that oh no look we were both
pissed whatever or is it just like you
did that and then we're supposed to
pretend that didn't happen and now we're
just going to talk about what Maddie got
on her test yeah well sometimes a good
nap or a good night's sleep can solve a
lot of emotional issues totally get it
but is there some if if you're looking
just at the texts like it begs the
question
wouldn't you take the nap and then go
Hey listen I just woke up from the nap
it turns out I was really tired like
does that not happen by text oh no
that's uh because sometimes it's hard to
probably apologize for being an
right so I think we use just text we
humans use
all kinds of forms of communication to
kind of vent I think it's the wrong
thing to do but people do do that text
has a permanence though it's writing I
mean it's writing she's used to think
like a lawyer I like anything like a
lawyer but lawyers think lawyers think
like detail you know and and why would
you write that down
like you know writing it down like would
you write it down and would you put it
on a billboard in Times Square because
like that's ex everything you say on
Facebook or Instagram Canon will be used
against you in a court of law like every
photo you post I mean that's going on
with uh what's his name Jake Paul or
whatever Paul and Dylan danis right now
that guy's girlfriend every picture has
ever been put on the internet of her by
her is being weaponized right now to
reference an earlier part of our
discussion that's love you take a big
risks big risk putting it out there yeah
um putting out there on text putting out
there on social media what is the reward
of doing it via text worthwhile I'm
listen the reward of love I think is
worth the risks of love but the benefit
of communicating by text does it Merit
that that risk of that being in writing
that the person can reflect on and
review and scroll back and get heated up
again about I don't know we just take
risks and we're vulnerable with each
other there may be something about text
that for whatever reasons inspires a
kind of candor
because I think it it is a new way to
communicate right in the scheme of
things and so sometimes you know we
don't know the thing until it's really
come into existence so I don't know I
think it started as something that we
just communicated in a very
extemporaneous unplanned way like texts
were meant to be I'm here I'm outside
whatever it might be
and so what happens when you start to
talk about more emotional deeper bigger
things or visceral things or more
emphatic passionate things using a
technology that was originally just
being used for the other purpose I don't
I don't know the answer that what I do
know is yeah as a lawyer
a from an evidentiary perspective
and B I just know what it looks like on
the outside like I I I know when I read
it what it looks like and that's that's
not always accurate like to just see the
it's like when you watch you know a
video of someone at just their worst
moment you know and the person that
tries to say but wait that's not me like
that was just me in that moment that was
me at this incredible low point and
I I think as a lawyer my job is to
weaponize that and to try to say okay
this this low point is indicative of who
they actually are yeah and when I'm
defending someone I'm supposed to say
you know well this is their low Point
we've all been to a low point and this
is just a moment in this person and to
judge them by that moment would you want
to be judged by your worst moment so I
have to be able to look at that both
directions
yeah I mean I don't think anyone looks
great on text I mean there's so much of
our communication that that is missing
your you know your your expression like
my sense of humor does not do well via
text like I I because I have like
sometimes a sarcastic sense of humor or
I have a dry sense of humor and it does
not always translate well to text the
Nuance of things is lost sometimes you
know yeah but that's what makes the risk
of it uh hilarious I mean the Emojis the
memes all that
um taking a risk the dry the there's a
risk with the text if you do some like
dark dry
statement right that's a joke and then
the pause and then there's no response
for a couple hours I mean that's
beautiful I don't know that's a that's
like a it's this you know it's it's the
gap between the two trapezes you know
like once you've hit send and you're
like well let's see where this goes like
this is coming back now you know and and
you're waiting and waiting it's like
that moment of just hang is yeah that's
a rush I mean that's a rush that's a
beautiful thing we'll have uh my friend
Michael malice living close by and if if
uh the courtroom or ever to see the text
between us I would we would be both in
jail for many many years